hey what's up welcome back to css3 in 30
days this is day seven we're going to be
doing some image manipulation purely
with CSS over here in my browser check
it out right here day seven image
manipulation I'm gonna show you what
we're gonna do so basically we're gonna
use these nice beautiful images that I'm
pulling from unrest plash and I'll show
you there in the markup in a moments how
that how that happens but what I'm doing
is I'm using some CSS 3 filters to
manipulate the images so here are the
original images right here and you can
see they're just normal images but then
down here they have different styles you
can see this first one is black and
white and when I hover it continue
changes back to its original color and
the second one is blurred and when I
hover it goes back to its original focus
so it looks like it has this kind of
cool focus effect and this one is
inverted if I hover it goes back to the
original image
this one is sepia tone and then when I
hover goes back to the original image so
it's pretty cool you could do some basic
photo editing and manipulation in CSS
without having to go into Photoshop so
if you want to make it image black and
white or sepia toned or you want to blur
it a little bit or you want to play
around with it like that you can just
use css3 so head over to the code editor
here and make sure you download the
course files for this lesson it is seven
image manipulation as always there's an
index a final and a sandbox file and the
index here I'm going to show you I'm
just pulling some images from unsplash
so basically this is like a placeholder
image you can pull them in like so so
unsplash tighty 500 by 300 is the
dimensions the query string image equals
110 74 which is the ID of the image you
if you change that it'll pull up a
different image so it's kind of a cool
way of showing images on your websites
for placeholders or for images because
unsplash is a free stock photography
site okay
so you can see here on each of the
images I have classes so I have the
image the first one is grayscale the
second one is blur invert and sepia and
in the final CSS you can see all this
the styles here which we're going to be
coding up it's pretty straightforward so
let's go ahead and open our sandbox
CSS and let's get started the first
thing we're gonna do is select all of
the images within the sandbox so sandbox
image and we're gonna say WebKit
transition all 0.3 seconds into YZ copy
that and just have a fallback for a
transition here beauty just like that
and what we're gonna do is we're also
gonna say sandbox image on hover and
we're just gonna say cursor crosshair
just for something different when you
hover over the image I want the cursor
to change to a crosshair
purely for user experience nothing else
okay and now let's get right to it we're
gonna say grayscale is the first set of
it the first image and we're going to do
a WebKit filter this is the CSS that
we're going to be doing you're gonna be
using it's a CSS style called filter but
WebKit filter is the the browser prefix
for WebKit and we're gonna say grayscale
and then in parenthesis you put the
amount you want it to be grayscale so
I'm just gonna say 1 for 100% because
you could do a sliding scale and let's
copy this paste it out and just do
filter whoa that was interesting there
we go save that and let's go check it
out so here we go we've got the
grayscale image here just like that so
that one we've changed it a grayscale so
now if I go back to the code editor and
I maybe I changes to like 0.5 and see
what that looks like you could see over
here it actually is 50% gray scale so
it's kind of a cool effect so you can
actually have it be varying degrees it
doesn't have to be hard black and whites
you know it could be any percentage in
between which is really cool I'm gonna
go back and change it to 1 and now what
I want to do is on hover I want it to go
back to its original a style in the
original image so I'm gonna paste the
same rule here and I'm just going to
change this to grayscale zero and
grayscale zero on hover so now if I save
that go back to the browser and when I
hover it's going to have that effect and
I can see when I'm hovering here it's
just turning it on and off it's not
doing the transition that we set up so
if I go back to my brow a code editor
here I can actually see that I've made a
typo in line seven sand box needs to be
sand box at the denounce and box so now
if I save that and check it out it
should have that effect beautiful nice
and subtle just like that alright so now
let's move on to the next image and
that's going to be the blur image so
it's just the class of blur we have
WebKit filter again we're just using
filters it's pretty simple and we're
using blur
we're gonna see three pixel blur you can
again you can change that to different
values and I'm gonna just have the
fallback here
just like so and let's go ahead and copy
that paste it and what we're gonna do
here is change the blur back to zero on
hover so we'll just do that right out
the gate save that check it out over
here in the browser and now if I scroll
down the image too it's blurred awesome
hover going back to normal it's fading
in and out looks really nice now what if
we made it like I don't know what's a 1
pixel blur look like let's check it out
in the browser again more subtle it's
just kind of slightly blurred and if we
did something wild like 10 pixels that
image is gonna be super blurry you can
hardly even notice it so that's kind of
a cool little effect you know maybe
that's coming at you're getting some
ideas thinking about what you could do
with that you know if you wanted to
reveal something if you have a portfolio
website you want to reveal you know you
this is your background and you have
text overlaid and then when you hover it
the image kind of fades in or whatever
you want to do there's certain things
that you could do just in CSS just to
give a nice user experience using the
WebKit filters ok so save that I'm just
gonna make it 3 pixels again now the
next one we're gonna change it to an
inversion of the color so all we're
going to do here is do the class of
invert and we're gonna do the WebKit
filter again and you guessed it invert
parentheses this is going to be 1 or 0 I
believe we could do a sliding scale
again we'll try it again in a moment and
I'm going to change this to filter
invert 1 and let's copy that do a
hovered version of that and again you
guessed it you're probably ahead of me
now invert 0 we're gonna switch it back
to normal on hover save it go to your
browser check it out it's fully inverted
the colors are when you hover it goes
back to normal now what if we changed it
to a different value like 0.5 again just
half does that actually work if you go
over to the browser it doesn't quite
look like it does
what if I know maybe I'll try a
different value
okay yeah it kind of does something
there
it looks like it's almost like an
opacity if I say that 2.09 so yeah it
kind of does the trick their owner if to
does anything know true doesn't do
anything so it's just kind of one and it
looks like you can do less so almost
looks like it's like an opacity how much
of it you can see it's not actually
converting the color it's so much as
it's just making it gray yeah so it's
kind of like it's not even opacity it's
just like you can't quite see the full
inversion so if you want to stick to the
inversion I don't really know when you'd
use this anyway one and zero stick to a
binary numbers here there it is
okay now the next one let's move on to
something else let's do sepia this is
one that I could see you using sepia
we're gonna do WebKit filter again and
we're gonna do sepia and one and we're
gonna do filter here and we're gonna
copy that out and we're going to paste
that we're gonna make it a:hover
and we're gonna change that back to zero
save that and let's check it out in the
browser and there is our sepia tone
right there and you hover it toggles it
in and out and so there you have it
there are some examples of the CSS
filters now if you want to play around
with them a little bit more you can
actually check out the css3 filter
property online google it w3schools comm
is a great resource and you can see all
the different versions and how to play
around with them so here for example
there these are the different filters so
there's blur which uses a pixel
measurement brightness contrast drop
shadows grayscale he rotate invert which
is actually percentage so we were
actually using just zeros and ones if we
wanted to use a percentage here that
might have been a better choice let's do
50% and 50% save that go to invert and
again the 50% was kind of like the 0.5
so maybe I don't really know what goes
on there
but if I do 70% you can see it partially
so yeah
I'm gonna stick to one for now unusual
let's go back to the browser here so you
can see there's opacity saturate if you
want to saturate the image a little bit
more sepia URL let's see if you want to
use XML files that has SVG filters and
then just initial and inherit so those
are the different css3 filter functions
that you can use feel free to read up on
it if you want or play around with it
and experiment and that is it for day
seven hang tight we have some more fun
stuff in fact we have a really cool
project that we're gonna build tomorrow
see you then
[Music]